Okay so now let us see how the AI
agent might go about building
an explanation that shows that
the object that have these properties
in fact is an instance of
this concept of a cup.
What I'll do here is to first sketch
out the explanation for you and
then I'll discuss how the AI agent
goes about building the explanation.
Let us first consider this part.
This is an abstraction that
we learn from the bowl.
The object carries liquid
because it is concave.
There is a similar abstraction
learned from the briefcase.
The object is liftable because
it is light and it has a handle.
Here's the abstraction that the air
agent learned from the glass.
The glass enables drinking
because it carries liquids and
because it is liftable.
So, in this way, the abstraction learned
from the glass gets connected to
the abstractions learned
from the bowl and
the abstraction learned
from the brief case.
Note that the effect here and
the abstraction from the bowl has become
the cause for the effect that was
the abstraction from the glass.
Similarly here, the effected object is
liftable was learned from the briefcase
example, but in the context of
the glass, this becomes the cause for
object enables drinking.
Let's shift to the fourth example for
brick.
>From there, one knows that the object
is stable because it is a bottom and
the bottom is flat.
Now, we can connect this causal
chain and this causal chain
into a more complex causal explanation
for why this object is a cup.
The call that we had said earlier and
the definition of a cup, that an object
is a cup if, it is stable and
it enables drinking,
now we have shown that in fact,
this particular object is a cup because
it is stable and it enables drinking.
In practice when an A Agent actually
goes about building this explanation,
it works backwards.
For the definition of the cup, it knows
that in order for an object to be a cup,
the object must be stable and
the object must enable drinking.
So the A Agent's senses' goal
of proving that the object is
stable into his memory.
Memory returns the example of a brick,
because a brick is stable, but the brick
said that the brick is stable because
it has a bottom and the bottom is flat.
So the air agent affects this causal
relationship from the brick example and
applies it to the object here.
Similarly for this part and
they asked for
the definition of the cup was
that it enables drinking.
So how can the A agent prove that
the object enables drinking?
This object only exists in the kitchen.
The air agent sensed the goal of proving
that the object enables drinking
induced memory.
Memory returns the example for glass
because the glass enables drinking.
It abstracts from glass the fact that
the object must carry a liquid and
the object must be liftable
in order to enable drinking.
That sets up some new
experiences with sub goals.
How can the area agent now prove
that the object can carry liquid?
That goes back into the memory, and
the example of a bowl is found.
And I think you can now see how the rest
of the explanation process would work.
Note this connects with a couple of
lessons we have learned earlier.
First you can see [INAUDIBLE]
reduction and application here.
Wanting to prove that object is a cup,
to do that we deduce the problem into
two smaller and simpler problems.
Let's prove that object is stable, let's
prove that object enables drinking, and
so on and so forth.
Second this connects with
the notion of planning.
When we were discussing planning
we had open preconditions.
Those were preconditions of a goal
which we needed to satisfy.
We use those open preconditions
to select operators,
a similar thing is happening here.
When we want to prove that
the object is a cup, then we have
two open preconditions, object is
stable, and object enables drinking.
These preconditions then become levels
while selecting explanatory proofs,
explanatory fragments that can
help fulfill those preconditions.
>> So the scenario of a robot
proving that an object is a cup is
a bit of a longer term scenario.
We're still a ways away from having
robots that walk around our house and
retrieve cups for us.
To take an example perhaps from
the near future, I can imagine one day
having a word processor that has built
into it some intelligence such that,
instead of choosing a file based
strictly on its file name,
I can say something like, get me that
important document from last Tuesday.
I myself might not remember
the filename or where I saved it, but
I remember that last Tuesday I was
working on an important document.
The intelligent search in
the word processor would
then iterate over the documents and say,
can I both prove that the document is
important and it is from last Tuesday?
Now the word processor might not have
a notion of importance built into it
naturally, but it knows documents I
considered important in the past.
And it might start to notice the
documents that have my header on them,
and have my signature at the bottom,
are important.
And from there,
it can start to build a case for
why that particular
document is important.
Coupled with just being able
to read the time stamp and
see if it's from last Tuesday,
it should be able to retrieve for
me documents that might be both
important and from last Tuesday without
me ever really knowing what the document
file name was or where I saved it.
>> This kind of explanation-based
learning actually occurs in our
everyday life.
So you are now constantly improvising.
Papers are blowing off my desk.
How can I stop them from blowing off?
So I need something to stop
them from blowing away.
What is other label what
can act as a paper weight?
A cup.
Here is a cup.
Let me put it on the paper.
This is an example of improvisation
where we use explanation-based learning
to realize that this is how we use
a flat bottom can act as a paper weight.
Here is another example.
I need to prop open a door,
a door stopper is not available.
What can I use?
Perhaps an eraser or a chair.
You and I do this kind of improvisation
all the time, and often we are building
these explanations that tell us that
an eraser can be used as a door stopper.